what's up guys Jerry here my hair looks
funky today I'm on the beat all right
I'm about to lay down the law I've got
too much energy right now uh yeah all
right I bet you're wondering why I made
all those police puns just now or not
because you know we made two of really
anyway I am making police puns because I
was treated to a screening of a film a
movie that came out just today depending
on when you watch this cold let's be
cops yes the new buddy comedy / cop
picture starring jake johnson who you
might know from the new girl safety not
guaranteed as the principal in the first
21 Jump Street movie as well as Damon
Wayans Jr who you might remember from
dance flick and I think also the new
girl at some point so let's get into
this let's be cops alright so this movie
centers around two guys the longtime
friends the roommates and they're both
sort of dealing with being 30 and not
having a lot going for themselves the
Damon Wayans Jr character is sort of
struggling at work no one takes him or
his ideas seriously he's having issues
with his you know self-confidence and
you know he's a timid guy trying to hack
it in the video game industry and Jake
Johnson is he doesn't exactly have a job
but he's got a lot of confidence he sort
of always mired in his past glory days
and whatnot and he doesn't really take a
lot of responsibility for anything so
you have these two guys who are you know
kind of a pair of odd ducks and you know
early on in this movie they attend their
college reunion and they sort of come to
see in great detail how lackluster and
unsatisfying their lives have become
since college you know
and it's after this point that things
start to heat up and get fun because if
you've seen the trailer you know they go
to this party thinking it's a costume
party so they dress up as cops when in
actuality it turns out to be a
masquerade party so they look like
doofuses but um after the party they're
sort of walking around the street and
people you know start to react to them
as though they're cops and then the
movie unfolds hijinks ensue as i'm sure
you can tell and i think the first and
foremost your enjoyment of this movie
hinges on one thing which is your
ability to suspend disbelief and to go
along with the ridiculousness of this
idea because movies like this I've often
heard the criticism from both critics
and viewers that you know all this would
never happen no one would put up with
this no one would get away with this and
it's true obviously so if you're the
type of person which wish I am who can
suspend disbelief if the movie you know
gives you enough reason to then I think
you'll have a really good time with this
it's um it definitely gets better as it
goes along and it does at least make an
effort to acknowledge that what they're
doing is a illegal and be you know sort
of ridiculous and improbable but this
movie it does ultimately end up being a
lot of fun it takes a little while to
establish a really good rhythm but Jake
Johnson and Damon Wayans Jr haven't won
a chemistry with each other and what's
interesting about this movie is that
part way through you know sort of
towards the end it takes a left turn it
becomes an actual cop movie more or less
I mean they shoot the villain stuff and
and the cop stuff like they would an
actual cop movie that's where I sort of
got to give the director of the most the
most praised here is because he jumps
back and forth between buddy comedy and
cop movie with a good amount of action
towards the end and it's shot well like
the action is good and you know it's
it's a lot of fun but after a while
things get serious and I believe that
tone shift so it's a little long winded
on the front end you know it's a little
choppy but it
good time I had a good time the comedy
is funny there are a lot of really fun
supporting characters and stuff Rob
Riggle is in there a lot of fun to watch
whenever he shows up and he's actually
got a pretty sizable role in here the
romantic female lead is good
keegan-michael key from Key & Peele is
hilarious in his small part Natasha
Leggero who's a comedian she's in here
for some pretty wacky scenes so there's
a lot of you know there's a lot of
character in here and the movie does
commit to itself you know it does commit
to its characters and it does commit to
being a cop movie when it wants to be a
cop movie when the action heats up all
the villains you know they take their
role seriously and you know that sort of
it works is like Jake Johnson and Damon
Wayans Jr really charming together and
there's a lot of good humor in there
it's not an airtight script there are
certainly plot holes and if you're
sitting there looking for them you will
find them it's not as consistent as the
hangover or horrible bosses or the kind
of comedies this movie it seems like
it's trying to be because it wants to
have an edge into a degree it does and
this in the second half of the movie it
definitely gets a lot tighter um but
it's it's a good time you know um it's
got a pretty low rating on rotten
tomatoes I think but you know what the
audience I was with had a good time
everyone clapped at the end um and it's
it's definitely I think anybody I think
you're gonna enjoy this if you if you go
check it out you know it's it's a fun
buddy movie it's a cool cop movie you
know they actually put a little thought
into it and it's nice you might you
might want to hit up a matinee just in
case but if y'all are looking for
something fun to do this weekend and you
don't necessarily want to go the
expendables 3 um yeah I'd say definitely
check out let's be cops it's not an
incredible movie but it is fun you left
a good taste in my mouth I actually had
a good time so if you can suspend your
disbelief enough to go along with this
ridiculousness um you know it's a good
time so yeah let's be cops what's your
favorite buddy cop movie let's talk
about that
that's that's it for now so until next
time the movie is let's be cops I am
Jerry and cheers